hello and welcome to conan o'brien needs
a friend
fine program for you in this installment
how does it work in podcasting episode
it's an episode yeah okay do you know
what you're doing i don't i really don't
know what these are you know for years
i'd say welcome to the show tonight
right even that wouldn't apply anymore
because
now it's the streaming era so god knows
when people are seeing things right but
so much of my life for so long was this
is the show tonight folks
and now we live in this other world
where someone may
download this good
so far so good 35 years from now true
and it should feel as relevant to them
then
as it does to us now to a certain extent
no that's why i like to try and keep
these things evergreen i don't mention
who's president i never refer to
anything that's happened in the news i
like to say generic things like
well uh it sure is good that the human
race still exists you know what you are
what you're the top gun maverick of
podcasting because they don't mention
the war and even the enemy fighters are
called fifth generation fighters and
it's the most benign non-offensive enemy
this is my favorite thing i went to see
the
and i really enjoyed it i really loved
the movie it was really fun but when it
was over and the lights came up i turned
to my son
and i said now why were we at war with
vermont
because it just really intrigued me that
you don't know what the country is they
don't really say but it looks a lot like
vermont
yeah speak too it's snow peaked hills
and evergreen trees and then my son was
like well they had a secret production
facility that was making maple syrup and
that's what we had to destroy
so we were just riffing off that but it
was so funny to me like vermont went and
did it yeah they threw down on us we got
to go after them bernie went rogue the
bad guys in that movie again
it was so good at like okay they seem
nefarious
i don't know why that country had such
better fighters than we do right it
doesn't make sense and i thought no we
spent a lot of money on our military i'd
like to speak to someone in our war
department
why do we have
far inferior fighter planes to vermont
it just doesn't seem right well i went
to see that movie and when in the end
not it's not really a spoiler but there
is a point where they end up in a
classic f-14 fighter jet i look down at
my seat
f14
what yeah oh in the theater oh i thought
you were referring to your [ __ ] as a
fighter jack wait i i thought that's
what i thought you were doing like i
looked down in my pants f-14 you dirty
devil i'm confused
what do you mean i was in the theater it
was in row f oh
no you guys are talking about keeping
this podcast evergreen you're talking
about a movie that just came out hey
when i watched the first star wars when
it was over i looked on it my seat it
was seat c3po come on see this guy knows
what i'm talking about
with yes
what movie did you see him you look down
in your seat
uh don't don't do that well please
don't make me think i don't know what's
the number what's the number movie 42
187
no first you got to think of it i went
to a blank cd i went to a blank 187
because 82.
yes right now i got it wrong once and
you gave me halloween i was doing a
funny riff on how you got it wrong
no i did wait he didn't i think he did i
think i got it right i think that's the
second that's multiple times no no no no
no no no no
he got it wrong the first time and this
was my clever call back to him getting
him no okay so i win once again no i'm
sorry what's this oh i'm getting an
award
wow conan wins again award it's a tissue
i've won 750 million of these in my
lifetime tissue box well it looks like a
tissue box to you but those of us when
they know know that that's not a puffs
plus lotion tissue box
that is
an award for once again winning anyway
go check out uh the new top gun movie
it's great ever agreed evergreen and we
really yeah exactly this is his
evergreens it gets because you know what
tom cruise will put out another one in
35 years yeah in 30. so this will still
be wrong check it out don't get monkey
pox yes who won the cup i don't know
i'll salute president joe rogan
oh god please he's built for politics
all right let's go
trying to think of a movie with a number
i'm sorry i'm still stuck on that i got
really nervous and i just blew it i'm
sorry what about um guess what
i remembered i once saw a really good
movie about sparta and i looked under my
seat afterwards i was in sitting in row
300.
nice okay yeah that's really good right
i went to see a classic screening of
deliverance and i looked down and i saw
that i was seating in row row your boat
oh god that's it i'm going to introduce
the guest i don't see i was thinking of
numbers no i'm sorry i don't know i
can't do the things that you guys do
you're my brains you can't do what
girlie just did
that's good that means you have no tumor
[Laughter]
that means
that means you're going to live
he's got something he's got something
pressing on no dude if this is better
this better because of kindergarten cop
when i looked down and i saw that i was
seated in row it's not a doomer that's
not even a doesn't know what's that oh
you're just ruining the thing yeah that
doesn't line up at all i'm trying to
think of you're out of order and you're
no she had a great ass
jesus he's out of control
out of control
you can't handle the truth there you go
there you go
row two can't handle the tooth no man
what i don't know i don't wanna no come
on
i can't do this unbelievable